Oh. Hmm.
Aww, he's using his jacket as some kind of
security blanket.
That's so cute and pathetic.
It really is.
You do you, weirdo.
Oh, hey, guys. I'm just sucking on my jacket.
A clump of honey candy got stuck right there
over a thousand years ago, and I can still
taste it.
You know who I bet would like some of that? Me.
Zoidberg.
Oh, no.
Zoidberg, you residue hog. Now all I taste is
crab juice.
So, buy another jacket candy.
I can't. They stopped making it after it got
reclassified as industrial glue.
Ah. Then I, Bender will recreate the recipe. Don't
forget, I came in third on Master Chef Junior.
May I have a taste?
Sure. You seem like the kind of guy who has a
mouth.
Whoa.
Diabetic coma.
I better add some sugar to make it less
sweet.
And just a touch of treacle to remind me of
my dear departed Aunt Juanita.
She drowned in treacle.
You know I'm dying on the floor.